If these expirements are to continue as requested.
We would again require access to the donor.
I will not dissapoint you again, Moff Gideon.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Mandalorian season
2 episode 4 video.
There were a bunch of big reveals a whole
bunch of Easter eggs so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes this season.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything
we'll do a giveaway for Disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your favorite Easter egg from the
episode in the comments careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet will do
top 10 and Easter eggs as we go along.
Starting with number 10, the title the episode
was the siege which is a reference to their
siege on the Imperial base during the episode.
The episode was directed by Carl Weathers
Greef carga himself to actually had a bunch
of action scenes way more action scenes that
I think that he got during season one earliest
bigger action scenes in terms of scope the
special-effects were actually pretty good
most of the special-effects have gotten a
big upgrade over season 1 there a couple scenes
in particular that all reference throughout
the video where they actually spent a lot
of time trying to get you to look in the background
just to see how much better it's gotten since
season one.
You also may have spotted the air during the
episode a lot of people been talking about
it since the episode dropped.
So if you look in the background of this firefight
you actually one of the production crew members
in frame in history close deafly does not
look like something that you would expect
to find in an Imperial base in the Star Wars
universe, but because Carl Weathers was directing
and Dave Filoni is directing episode 5 I kind
of felt like this episode was not gonna be
the Ahsoka episode.
Even though they teased her at the end of
episode three, but the episode begins with
him limping through space like the razor crest
is ready to fall apart at the seams at any
moment.
He's even got baby Yoda working in the conduits
on repairs with him is like rocket trying
to get baby grew to work on the detonator
button with him and guarding to the galaxy
to there were a couple baby grew reference
moments during the episode where you have
baby Yoda doing things that they be crew did
during guarding to the galaxy to you all probably
know what I'm talking about.
As they take a break to eat some food he decides
he can't make it to Ahsoka on Corvus without
stopping back on Nevarro for repairs.
He takes his helmet off just a little bit
to sip some soup is the first time he's done
at this season.
Baby Yoda actually takes note of it looks
at his face and after the Boca tan reveal
and episode three now.
Everyone's wondering if this is going to lead
eventually to man dough taking his helmet
off in a bigger way.
Realizing that this entire time he's been
part of this special deathwatch cult, not
the actual main body of Mandalorian's themselves
who all take their helmets off all the time.
Number nine.
Return to the forge back on Nevarro and their
former forge room.
The armorer has long since taken off nowhere
to be found.
So far this season, but she is still alive
out there somewhere in a note to the big cold
reveal and episode three people are wondering
now if their faction is actually part of the
deathwatch Mandalorian's that split in followed
Darth Maul and became the Mauldalorians because
they had horns on their helmet.
She has horns on her helmet.
So maybe the crazy children of the watch are
actually the Mandalorian's that followed Darth
Maul that is the theory that started since
last week's episode will find out if we get
more information about them, but it seems
like a group of Aqualish thugs have taken
up residence in the forge in the discounting
the spoils of their recent take.
They got some of the same sorgandrink that
they may from the krill that they were drinking
and episode one on tattooing in that we saw
them farming in season one episode for so
it seems like that's a pretty popular drink
around this part of the galaxy they start
fighting over money prepare to cut up this
large ferret like creature.
Even though the ferret can't talk you could
make another guardians of the galaxy rocket
reference because there's so much baby grew
baby Yoda connections during the episode than
Cara Dune comes in and cleans them out and
then takes all the possessions in the money
back to the people that they stole it from
the fair winds up befriending her then shows
up again at the end of the episodes, so maybe
she's found herself a new pet.
Then she and greef carga greet mando as he
arrives the baby Yoda he sort of exits comedicly
as they lay in the razorcrest, but he is to
climb out of the back because the hatch was
open all the way they linger a lot on the
repair text we find out why by the end of
the episode because of the Moff Gideon plan,
but the costumes that they're wearing actually
seem like they're modeled based on original
Star Wars Kenner action figures, like the
old school action figures back from Empire
strikes back and return of the Jedi era.
The reason why he asks them for a line of
credit is just because it's so expensive to
repair the razor crest and he gave up all
the money from his recent bounties in exchange
from the assist from the new Republic pilots
trapper wolf played by Dave Filoni himself
and Carson Teva later show up during the episode.
Greef carga explains that he's just been doing
a lot of clerical work since season one, but
it's mostly been Cara Dune going around actually
doing the work of cleaning the town up the
number eight.
He takes them on a tour of the city and shows
in the new school, so they spent a bunch of
time walking around so notice how much more
they focus on them walking around showing
you the actual town from different angles
and all the backgrounds to their mostly doing
this just to show you how much more sophisticated
they've gotten with that rear projection technology
the LED walls that allow them to make all
the different environments their couple moments
when you can tell that it's rear projection
and not an actual full landscape like it's
not absolutely perfect, but in this scene
here.
If you look in the background you can see
a statue dedicated to IG-11 lauding him as
a local hero.
Greef carga also makes a couple references
to the new Republic being just as inept at
taking care of the outer rim territories as
the Empire was like everyone to just leave
the task of governing the outer rim to the
outer rim themselves.
It pays a better picture for how everyone
out here actually feels about the new Republic
like yes, you got rid of the Empire, but we
didn't really care about them.
We don't really care about you.
We just want to do our own thing later in
the episode.
They also make a reference to the way that
the core worlds feel about the outer rim.
It's kind of a similar story where the people
in the core worlds don't really care about
what's happening in the outer rim either will
or that they converted the bar from season
one when they were holed up under fire from
Moff Gideon's forces and turned it into a
school for local children.
The schoolteacher is a C-3PO protocol droid
to when she talks about the Corellian run.
That's a major hyperspace route mentioned
in an episode of the clone wars called the
Citadel when they reference the Hydian way.
That's just another big hyperspace route mentioned
in an episode of the clone wars called R2
come home.
Greef carga wants to drop off baby Yoda just
because the gonna be doing the siege that
the explains to Amanda later and they do want
to take baby Yoda with them.
The protocol droid starts referencing a lot
of the different sectors of the galaxy the
different regions of space she talks about
the core worlds the mid-rim where most of
the galaxy's population resides the busier
plants of the galaxy.
She mentions the expansion region the inner
rim the colonies the deep core and of course
the quote of quote unknown regions she talks
about the capital of the Old Republic being
within the core worlds.
That's coruscant she's talking about, but
remember the Old Republic is different from
the Republic and now are right at the beginning
of the new Republic era, but number seven
baby Yoda versus the kid so you have baby
Yoda getting super hungry seeing the kid sitting
next and eating what looks like macaroons
or the Star Wars version of macaroons they
really just play for common he does have a
funny moment of him using the force to snatch
the cookies when he's not looking, but also
I think they did that to remind you of what's
happening later in the episode when they have
the big cloning reveal in the big Moff Gideon
reveal the midichlorians, the force.
That's why were using this blood from baby
Yoda while that's happening though.
The droid also mentions the akkadese maelstrom.
That's the maelstrom that contains the kessel
run from solo Star Wars story in a big maw
creature, the number six welcome back Horatio
sans from season one.
They bring back his character mandos original
bounty from the beginning of season one episode
one whose name is actually mythrol.
It kinda seems like he's doing his race is
equivalent of kissing himself in fear.
The minute he sees Mando the Greef carga says
that he just been his bookkeeper for a long
time in the whole reason why there was a bounty
on them in season one is because he stole
a bunch of his money and took off for a couple
funny moments in the episode later where he
chops a bunch of time off that debt to keep
him from taking off and leaving them stranded
he jokes about still not being able to see
clearly out of one eye having gone into the
Carbonite freezing which is a call back to
han solo suffering from Carbonite blindness
temporarily after coming out in return of
the Jedi they given the whole plan about rating
the Imperial base that's left from before
the Moff Gideon's been using it still manned
by skeleton crew Greef carga tries to play
it off like it's this really good thing that
they're getting rid of the last of the imperials,
but really he's meant to be a true, neutral
character he benefits because he wants to
turn Navarro into a major trade hub for the
sector of space which would mean even more
money for them long-term, but number five
the siege on the Imperial base.
So we learned that the traveling in a modified
X 35 land speeder which is just like Luke
Skywalker's from a New Hope.
They keep referencing all the lava which is
nice call back to moose to far, and sell us
if you played any the battlefront games just
other lava planets that look very similar
to this terrain Mando uses jetpack to take
out some of the storm troopers they played
for a little bit of comedy with them just
tossing them off of the edge and them crashing
below.
They reference the Trexler marauder.
Obviously they're gonna sell that as a toy
anytime you see them shout out something really
cool and episode of vehicle or new character.
That's gonna be a new action figure a toy
that they're gonna sell but you probably remember
this from season one episodes seven and eight,
because it's the troop transport that they
rolled into town on they decided the gonna
take out the cooling tower which is gonna
cause the lava to completely destroy the base
then they make a really cool reference to
the code cylinders.
So if you actually never realized what these
special cylinders are that are on all these
Imperial uniforms like those little silver
cylinders those are code cylinders they just
use those to get into classified areas or
get access to classified computers.
They don't do no rank or anything like that
but if you see certain officers with more
of them, it just means that their higher rank.
They have access to more classified data make
a couple funny references to Star Wars New
Hope and Obi-wan has to disable the shields
on the death Star is basically the same set
up.
The also made a similar joke about there being
no guard rails anywhere on the death Star
during the family guy blue harvest parody
episode, the number four.
The secret cloning facility, so they come
on some Imperial scientists are trying to
purge all this classified data in they find
all these cloning tanks with what looks like
a failed genetic experiments.
They unlock the hollow recording in his Dr.
Pershing back from season 1 talking about
how all the trials ended catastrophically
with donors rejecting blood transfusions the
donor with what he calls high quote of quote
M count clearly M is a reference to midichlorians
because later he talks about the child, baby
Yoda and taking blood from and I can only
take so much without killing him.
We need access to the asset again.
They find out that it's only three days old,
so that's how they learn that Moff Gideon
survived the big explosion of the Tie outlander
and season one.
You have to remember that man dough didn't
make it to the cockpit in time to catch his
hollow recording so this is his first time
learning that he still alive their couple
more Wilhelm screams as the storm trooper
start piling in in then they take off as Mando
goes back to town to grab baby Yoda in the
razor crest before more imperials can show
up to steal him the number three.
The big speeder chase with the troop transport
obviously when it is gonna happen because
it was in all the trailers pretty prominently.
They take off over the edge, crushing myth
role's precious landspeeder.
RIP press f in the chat.
The base finally blows in an explosion of
lava just as the Tie outlander's take off
after them there able to take out all the
speeder bikes pretty easily, but it takes
man dough in the razor crest to save them
from the Tie outlander's after their tour
it is taken out the special effects seem way
more sophisticated than they were during season
one.
So I'm excited to see how these evolve season
to season, year to year, especially with the
other new Star Wars Disney plus series.
They the funny baby Yoda baby grew guarding
to the galaxy to moment where he throws up
just like baby group did after they did all
the different jumps between the galaxies.
Then Mando leaves directly to take baby Yoda
to Ahsoka Tano in next week's episode five
wall number two.
Welcome back, Carson Teva and Dave Filoni
the exact same to Republic pilots from episode
to show up.
Dave Filoni himself doesn't cameo during the
episode, but they have both of their X wing
so its imply that he's there as well, only
Carson Teva appears on screen.
He seems like he's trying to fill out a report
about the destruction of the Imperial base
and find out what's going on with the razorcrest
just because are keeping tabs on him Greef
carga tries to pass it off like is just a
sensor air our logs can identify anything
pre-Empire.
But it's clear, the Carson Teva can kind of
rolls his eyes into the back of his head knows
exactly was happening.
He was happy to let Mando go in a previous
episode like he senses that Mando was trying
to do good things.
So is not like you trying to arrest him or
anything like that they reference coruscant
again.
I'm kinda wondering if we're actually going
to visit at some point during the Mandalorian.
Then he goes to trying get Cara Dune to join
the new Republic again.
Remember she used to be a new Republic shock
trooper she was a deserter in the reason why
he's not trying to arrest her is because Greef
carga sort of smoothed all that over in exchange
for her becoming his enforcer.
He explains that he was also fighting in the
battle with the rebellion near all the wrong
when it was destroyed because she's from all
drawn and how she lost all of her friends
and family, he leaves new Republic insignia
and she kind of makes you wonder whether or
not she's ever going to rejoin but are they
for the most part she's on a similar trajectory
is the Mandalorian when it comes to joining
the other Mandalorian's like man dough gets
the opportunity, but he says no I'm busy I
have this other mission this other life that
I'm leaving right now, but in terms of larger
overarching plot the thing that they let you
know.
During this conversation, is that nobody in
the core worlds believes that anything is
happening in the outer rim, meaning that they
don't know about Moff Gideon, or they don't
believe what Moff Gideon is doing.
Then of course number 1 Moff Gideon's new
Star destroyer in the force sensitive hybrid
clone super commando troopers will see what
Dave filoni and Jon Favreau are actually calling
those special super troopers, but is flying
in Arquitens class modified Star destroyer.
It looks really cool.
Obviously they're gonna be selling this is
a toy as well.
The scene is a very original trilogy type
of Star destroyer reveal scene with the ship
slowly entering frame and being so huge that
it just takes up the entire screen.
They reveal that one of the repair techs planted
a secret tracking device on the razorcrest
so they can clock them around the galaxy.
This is new Imperial character.
They don't give her a name, they just refer
to hers the comms officer who then goes and
reports the news to Moff Gideon and revealed
that he's developed a large squadron maybe
the whole division of black armored super
commandos, which you know based on this episode,
its imply that there is a product of the genetic
testing with baby Yoda's blood giving them
maybe some limited force abilities are making
them force sensitive more easily controlled
by Moff Gideon is generally making them way
more powerful than common storm troopers or
the clone troopers, but obviously episode
five.
Next week is going to be the Ahsoka Tano episode,
it was written and directed by Dave Filoni
the person who created the Ahsoka character
with George Lucas she's gonna be played by
Rosario Dawson.
So if you spotted any other big Easter eggs
during the episode that I didn't mention the
video just write them below in the comments
and obviously I'll do more bonus videos for
a lot of the bigger reveals my season 2 episode
5 video will post next Friday, just like normal
as long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos when
I post them while you wait for everything.
Click here for my new Mandalorian season 2
Ahsoka Tano video and click here for my Mandalorian
season 2 episode 3  video thank you so
much for watching
everyone stay safe this is the way!